[Music]
now to our cases across clark county
they've been dropping in recent weeks
we're seeing about 180 cases per 100 000
people now again that number needs to be
below 100 in order to ease restrictions
and get those masks off now the test
positivity rate is sitting at 10.8
percent which is down from 11
yesterday
well state health officials say a
nursing shortage is raising the red flag
as the covet fight continues according
to the executive director of the nevada
hospital association the main issue has
to do with the unvaccinated which make
up about 90 percent of patients
hospitals in northern nevada are close
to capacity and could force ambulances
to take patients to distant medical
centers dr chris lake says hospitals are
working to find a solution
we are changing the way that hospital
staff we're using team nursing
approaches we're assigning physicians uh
to certain floors
so that we can we can use our personnel
in a
in a manner where they can treat the
most patients with who we have
well dr chris lake says the average
hospital cost listened to this of a
covet patient is about 20 000 a day and
that obviously can be avoided if the
community does its part to stay healthy
and get vaccinated